you know that visualpolitik is one of
the few political channels that pays a
lot of attention to latin america one of
the least covered regions in the world
perhaps that is why many of you have
often asked us to talk more about latin
america well
we have a solution
[Music]
latam politik a newsletter that we make
together with geopolitical consulting
firm
perch perspectives if you subscribe
every month you'll receive 12
newsletters with the best information
and analysis on latin america to keep
you up to date and better understanding
everything that is happening in this
region the cost you can subscribe for
less than 35 cents per newsletter less
than a small taco or donut a week in
return you'll be kept up to date on all
the major happenings in the region and
better understand
all of the possible implications in
addition all of you who support us at
patreon level 4 and five will receive
latin politic
at zero cost you can find all the info
at latimepolitik.com
well it seems china is back the
emergence of the asian giant is changing
everything we're talking about a new
superpower in all fields economic
political and also
military so far on visualpolitik we have
talked a lot about china
it's a topic that we are passionate
about and that is no secret but what we
haven't covered before is what the
powers of what we would call the western
bloc
are doing to counter the growing
influence of china and therefore of the
chinese communist party in international
politics
[Music]
in absolute and temporal terms china's
economic growth
is political and now also its military
influence over the last 30 years has
little or no precedence never before has
a country positioned itself at the
forefront of world politics and
economics in such a short time evidently
this has geostrategic and economic
consequences
at the global level the emergence of
china has been positive for the world we
are talking about a gigantic new market
and a decisive contribution to an
enormous expansion of the purchasing
power of the world's population
nevertheless the type of regime that
pools the strings in china poses many
challenges for countries such as the
united states the uk
japan south korea australia or even due
to its demographic size and proximity to
india it is precisely for this reason
that several years ago some mechanisms
were put in place if they can be called
mechanisms whose mission is to unite the
liberal democracies of the asia pacific
region to support each other and
avoid falling under the thumb of beijing
instruments such as
the quad this is an organization a tool
that could become a regional
counterweight to china's power and
influence
if it were to fully develop although the
truth is that today
that seems a long way off quad alliance
of us
japan india and australia is part of
biden's plan to contain china but some
experts aren't so sure
cnn so do you want to find out what the
quad is all about and what it consists
of as well as
what opportunities it offers of course
you do so let's get cracking
[Music]
the asia pacific four
if the north atlantic treaty
organization nato was created as a
counter to the soviet union in europe
the quad was created to counter china
well
at least that was the initial idea
reality is
always more complicated later on
the quad is an informal association
initiated in 2007 and formed by four
countries the usa
india japan and australia an association
with other countries such as
singapore south korea new zealand and
vietnam who have occasionally
collaborated however we are talking
about something
very different from nato which is a
formal structured
co-financed and eminently military
organization today
the quad is far from being anything like
that it is more like the embryo of a
nato for the asia pacific which however
has not yet come to full gestation so
what are the problems the lack of
agreement and compromise between
countries
and the many economic interests that
would come into play at the event of
creating a let's call it
anti-china block in a region that
currently moves like or not
in the wake of the asian giant
[Music]
in other words the current quad is a
kind of organized forum where its four
members negotiate and agree on political
military and security issues but why
exactly was the quad conceived
in 2007
well you see the idea came from the then
japanese prime minister shinzo abe who
had the goal of creating something like
an
asian arc of democracy in other words an
alliance of the leading free and
democratic countries in the asia pacific
region at the same time it repositioned
japan as a leading power
and it has to be said not simply a
passive one so what happy had in mind
was to
establish an alliance that would serve
as a counterweight to chinese power an
alliance that would include countries
such as south korea mongolia
india and australia among many others
however this never materialized and
although the quad was established in
2007 comprising the four countries
mentioned above things didn't really get
off to a great start
for example australia withdrew from the
quad in february 2008 because the then
prime minister labour's kevin rudd
wanted closer ties with china to boost
bilateral economic relations besides the
land of kangaroos and koalas was not too
keen on getting involved in a formal
multilateral alliance it preferred to
negotiate its own bilateral agreements
something that pretty obviously went
against the idea of the quad itself with
the result that it ceased to make sense
and was deactivated so to speak entering
a long kind of dormancy from which it
was not to awaken
until almost 10 years later in 2017.
that year at an izane summit in manila
shinzo abe who is still prime minister
of japan
managed to revive the quad with a
quadrilateral agreement with india's
narendra modi australia's malcolm
turnbull
and the united states donald trump since
then the quad is still
there although when all is said and done
with a currently very
low profile
it is generally considered that the 2007
quad was a good idea but kind of ahead
of its time but that now in 2021 it
makes
much more sense what's more there is
already talk of a quad plus or a quad
2.0 and extended a renewed version of
the quad with more participating
countries and more strategic
implications an idea that is underway
that could finally materialize into
something concrete
very soon despite the differences in
perspectives and opinions the one thing
that is clear is that the quad of the
future
won't be the one envisioned by shinzo
abe and so what are we referring to then
well
check this out
[Music]
a nato for asia
check out these statements this is not a
rivalry between the united states and
china this is for the soul of the world
this is about whether there will be a
world that operates on a rules-based
international order system or one that's
dominated by a coercive totalitarian
regime like the one in china
mike pompeo ex-secretary of state of the
united states of america pompeo mike
pompeo the most visible face of the
trump administration in
asia quickly became a staunch supporter
of the quad he did so to the point that
he went so far as to want the group to
move towards an asian nato that would
attract more and more countries
now is this even feasible would it be
good for the region and would it make
any sense
well it turns out that on these issues
there are opinions to suit all tastes
[Music]
on the one hand there are those who
think that china and its power should
not be fought militarily because its
influence in the world is merely
economic and commercial and not military
china's way of extending its tentacles
is in addition to trade with all kinds
of countries through direct investments
particularly in southeast asia
africa and latin america surely the
greatest exponent of this type of
strategy would be the one belt
one road initiative which we've already
spoken about here on visual policy
of course the western powers and the
asian countries aligned with them are
not so sure at this stage that they can
compete with china in that league and
neither is it clear to them that the
military emergency that we will soon be
talking about on this channel so don't
forget to subscribe
is not going to be the biggest challenge
of all sooner or later
this is precisely why trump or rather
mike pompeo wanted to turn the quad into
a
military alliance similar to what nato
is in europe just keep in mind that if
this were to be carried out it's
potential members which in addition to
the four founding members could include
countries such as south korea and
singapore have a combined annual
military budget
four times larger than that of the
people's republic of china but
wait just a moment because it doesn't
seem like an easy thing
to accomplish even among the four
current members there are many
disagreements
india for example is unwilling to
participate in such an alliance
that kind of nato mentality has never
been india's if it has been there in
asia before
i think it's in other countries and
regions not in mine s
jaishankar external affairs minister of
india also
we cannot forget that we are talking
about asia pacific region a region where
countries are as open as they are
suspicious
of each other for example it is hard to
imagine a scenario in which japan
and south korea integrate their armed
forces into the kind of asian nato
sharing military infrastructure
intelligence and even rights of passage
through their territory exactly the same
could be said for
many other countries in south east asia
so no we're not exactly talking about an
easy path here
so how far could the quad really go well
the safest thing to do and perhaps for
the moment the most
reasonable is for it to become a
political economic and commercial
alliance after all if china uses
economics and trade as its main weapon
of influence why not use the same tools
to retaliate
[Music]
this was more or less the idea of former
us president barack obama with the
trans-pacific partnership agreement or
tpp which was to create a giant free
trade area between countries not allied
with china its members included all quad
members except
india as well as others such as vietnam
malaysia and singapore
the problem is that trump withdrew from
the tpp in january 2017 and the
agreement failed to achieve its goal to
serve as a counterweight to china and
unite the
asia pacific region around a free trade
area with rules driven and overseen by
the united states
[Music]
now things have changed and the white
house has a very different foreign
policy approach and this is exactly
where the quad could be an alternative
opportunity to regain u.s presence in
the asia pacific and create a club of
regional democracies cooperating outside
chinese pressures for the moment u.s
president joe biden seems enthusiastic
about the idea and wants to promote this
group in any way he can
to make up for lost time in the region
whether or not all this comes to
fruition means to be seen
but for the moment the quad has already
begun to serve a purpose
in fact in march 2021 the quad heard its
first formal
meeting the quad aims to increase
vaccine production to 1 billion doses
for southeast asia voice of america u.s
president joe biden and the prime
ministers of japan
india and australia discuss strategies
to counter china's rising influence in
the indo-pacific region including an
offer to match beijing's ambitious
vaccine diplomacy it was a meeting that
served to create a collaborative
strategy and develop a kind of vaccine
diplomacy parallel to the chinese one it
would be the group's first formal and
coordinated
joint action this is a milestone that
could be the quad's first operational
experiment an experiment in which tasks
would also be distributed taking
advantage of the strengths of each of
the members
with indian manufacturing u.s technology
japanese and american financing and
australian logistics we committed to
delivering up to one billion doses
jake sullivan u.s national security
advisor the question
is will this kind of soft diplomacy be
enough well
perhaps not on its own but whatever
could be combined with intelligence
agreements we are not talking about
anything far-fetched here in fact it is
something that
already exists it was created in the
1940s to counter the intelligence of the
ussr
and perhaps it would not be crazy for
the quad to become part of it what are
we talking about we're talking about the
five
eyes that's right the five eyes that
stare at every movement in this region
of the world so do you want to know
exactly what five eyes consists of if so
check this out
the five all-seeing eyes
as if it were straight from a science
fiction movie there is a global
intelligence alliance formed by five
allied countries whose mission is to
anticipate the movements
of their countries hostile to their
interests the five eyes alliance it is
the world's oldest intelligence alliance
comprising the united states the united
kingdom australia canada
and new zealand
at the time of its inception in 1946 the
idea was to create a coalition that
through the exchange of intelligence
information would enable these five
countries to decipher the communications
of the eastern communist bloc
and thus anticipate its actions
obviously today's rules are pretty
different because the communist bloc no
longer exists so the five eyes today
focus mainly on russia north korea and
of course china
in fact china blamed the member
countries of this alliance for the sort
of crusade that was launched against
huawei in 2018 and for the company's
alleged exchanges of confidential
information with the chinese government
and the theft of military technology
[Music]
so why is this important well if in
addition to becoming a diplomatic
political and commercial alliance the
quad were to be integrated along the
lines of the five eyes model the damage
to china in terms of influence could be
much greater the world's most powerful
countries could share what they know
about china with each other study plans
and operations to ensure security and
act together to preempt potential
threats from beijing doesn't it seem to
you that this would undermine the
chinese communist party's ability to
play the game or at least
make it think twice before acting
it doesn't sound like a bad idea however
i'm sorry to tell you that it doesn't
seem very likely that japan
and india will manage to integrate into
the intelligence alliance with the same
level of cohesion as the other four
member countries in any case
these are some of the main moves with
which the united states seeks to balance
its presence in the region and
be a counterweight to china and now it's
over to you do you think the quad
alliance could be effective in
countering china in the asia-pacific
region do you think the quad should be a
diplomatic and commercial alliance or
should it aim to be more of an asian
nato including intelligence integration
leave us your answers in the comments
below and as we always say if you like
this video don't forget to subscribe so
you don't miss anything new
coming to the channel all the best i'll
see you next time and if you want to
learn more about politics and hear even
more of my lovely voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider
media.com podcast see you there